[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today John is
starting off this hour in Chicago he
John how are
you doing well good what's up uh so I
was a sucker and I bought a motor home
when I got a uh remote uh job that paid
a lot more and of course I traveled all
all over the United States the last
couple years but uh I realized that um I
want to get out of De I want to get away
from that and of course I want to get
rid of the motor home and as that seems
to be hard without you know just trying
to sell it so I'm just seeing what my
options are what do you owe on the
mobile
home uh
70,000 and what's it
worth uh it's worth probably about uh
between 60 65 okay that's not too bad
you have any
money uh don't have much money
how much do you
have I had about 5,000 that I could put
towards it so you could close the gap
and sell
it yeah and and that that was my first
initial thought too um I had thoughts
about just letting go back to the bank
but I wasn't for sure what to do with
that oh you don't let it go turn it in
don't turn it in no here here's the
problem okay if it's worth 65 and you
voluntarily repossess it you're going to
have a repossession on your record
number one number two they're going to
sell it for 40 on the repo lot and
they're going to sue you for the
difference so you control the sale price
and you cover the difference you'll get
a lot more for it and you won't have as
much difference to cover or as much
hassle so now what you've got is the
hassle of selling a $65,000 $70,000
motor home which is a pain in the butt
to do but you can do it oh definitely
you can do it and it's a whole lot less
of a pain in the butt than having a repo
and having them chase you around for 40
Grand yeah because CU that's a funny
thing you say that because surrendering
a car or turning it in sounds a lot
better than repo but really what it is
is a repossession oh it's a voluntary
repossession and let me tell you if they
come and hook a wrecker and steal it in
the middle of the night or you take it
down there and hand them the keys it
shows exactly the same on your record
both are a
repossession okay so one's voluntary and
one's involuntary but the credit report
does not distinguish between the two and
uh people ask have you ever been
possessed they don't ask have you ever
been voluntarily repossessed that's a
very good point Have you ever filed
bankruptcy yes period or no it's not
there's not a oh well sort of there's
not a middle answer you did or you
didn't right and so that's that's the
problem with this and so yeah please
folks sell your stuff and cover the
difference with a loan sell your stuff
and cover the difference with cash uh
control the price of the sale of
something you're in the hole on that
you're upside down on like an RV I'm
really shocked pleasantly John that that
thing's worth as much as it is you must
have put a lot down on it to only
070 and it be worth 65 after you've
driven it around all over the place well
hey let me ask you a guidance question
because some people might be wondering
this that are listening let's say you've
got whether it's an RV or a vehicle
you're upside down and maybe you found
the cash to fill the Gap but it requires
you to do a personal sale like you're
going to for sale by owner yeah that's
fine but I guess the qu the question I'm
asking is how long would you stay on
sale by for sale by owner before you
would go to a dealership to sell it or
you know go through a dealership well
here's the thing I if the data indicates
from Kelly Blue Book that the car is
worth $2,000 and you put it on the
market for $20,000 and it goes a month
and you get zero nibbles car is probably
not worth $20,000 yeah drop it turns out
KBB was probably wrong so the car is
probably 18,000 so you're going to drop
your price uh but the dealer is going to
give you 15 right so we can do several
series of price drops and reset resets
until you get down to dealer and if the
dealer will give you 15 and the Public's
going to give you 15 then I'll deal with
you know it's worth it you know that's
the real price it's an easier
transaction to do it with a dealer but
it's very seldom because dealers if the
car really won't sell for 20 MH a dealer
really doesn't want it for 15 yeah
that's because their job is to resell
and make the spread yeah they're buying
to inventory to make a profit on it and
so they're not evil they're not doing
anything wrong but they're buying it
wholesale to sell it retail and if you
can't sell it at retail they probably
can't either I think a lot of people
avoid selling their own vehicle because
they're thinking oh this is a hassle
this is a hassle something I've never
done before you know but we go to a side
hustle and we make a th000 bucks or we
can go through this Hassle and save
$5,000 I agree so yeah let's do the
hassle hello it's worth it it's worth it
it's a it's a nice part-time job to go
sell your RV right right you know it's
um you set the hour make a lot more on
that then you will deliver in Pizza I
can tell you that so